hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a pharmacogenomic
approach to medical cannabis presented
by Jhon Marku director and chief
scientific officer Americans for safe
access
I am Xavier Gutierrez of lab routes and
I will be your moderator for today's
event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotion of
board at the bottom and/or center of
your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Marku I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello thank you for tuning
in to this webinar on a pharmacogenomic
approach to medical cannabis so as was
mentioned I work with Americans for safe
access which is a medical cannabis
advocacy group it was founded in 2002
with the mission of ensuring safe and
legal access to medical cannabis for
research and therapeutic purposes basa
focuses on direct action education of
both law makers doctors and patients as
well as making policy can
received and research recommendations
I'd encourage you to check out safe
access now org for a wealth of free
reports resources provided by the
nonprofit as well as our patient focused
certification program which contains
training and product certification
information for medical cannabis
products a part of this presentation
some of these slides actually come from
our educational materials which are
available on our patient focused
certification website today we're going
to cover the basics of the
endocannabinoid system or the ECS some
of the basics of administering cannabis
products how they're administered what
are some of the issues with the
administration now interacts with the
system called the ETS or endocannabinoid
system we're gonna talk about a field of
research that i'm very interested in and
have i guess as part of the soldier been
advising a pharmacogenomic company that
is interested in reducing adverse events
and drug drug interactions with patients
who are using medical cannabis products
both their personal life and in research
studies and we'll discuss some of the
variables and dosing and some
fascinating research about why people
may be responding very differently to
teach need and lastly land with
discussing some network capability eight
network capabilities in areas for
research there's a lot of interesting
research going on right now a lot of
really fun institutions if you're
interested for learning more about
really harnessing the power of medical
cannabis so the endogenous cannabinoids
system or endocannabinoid system was
fairly recently established in the early
90s the receptors were discovered which
led to the foundation of the endocrine
system you know now before that no one
really knew
quite how cannabis was working in the
60s a THC was purified and isolated from
the cannabis plant both in the Czech
Republic and at a university in Israel
and from there they were able to create
a lot of synthetic versions of the
radioactive versions in trace where it
went throughout the body and they found
specific protein sites called
cannabinoid receptors and we'll discuss
those a little bit more in detail later
but why they thought it might make a
good medicine is because the receptors
were found nearly everywhere in large
abundance probably one of the most
abundant proteins in the brain are the
receptors for this system that also
interact with THC however one thing
that's really interesting about these
receptors are found everywhere in the
brain except the brainstem and the brain
stem controls respiration and that's one
of the reasons why there's been no
report of a toxic lethal overdose of
cannabis is because of lack of those
receptors in the brain stem but they're
found pretty much throughout the human
brain and throughout the body um oops so
what does this system do well it helps
us to eat sleep relax forgetting protect
is the term that's been coined
cannabinoids such as THC and the
naturally made compounds like Ananda
mine they help us to basically stimulate
our appetite they help us to relax just
asleep they help control pain and
inflammation they also help regulate
memory they help us forget things which
is a very very important thing I'm I
live in New York and I am in California
now if I had remembered every face I saw
in the last two days of travel my head
would explode so it's really important
to have a system that's functioning
properly to get rid of information
that's no longer useful or perhaps
harmful and I think this is a very
fascinating area because of the
potential research in mental health and
post-traumatic stress disorder this
system is also a protective system the
compounds on the cannabis plant while
they can cause intoxication they're
non-toxic they do not damage cells they
don't kill cells in the system within
our body actually actively works to make
sure the body's in homeostasis spitting
things back down to normal
and keeping things from getting too
excited so this system within our body
is encoded by DNA it generates the
little machines that generate the
natural TC like compounds in our body
that produce the cannabinoid receptors
and if this system is out of whack
brothers mutation as has been described
some human populations this is thought
to be part of a system a part of a
deficiency syndrome called clinical
endocannabinoid deficiency syndrome
first described in 2004 by my colleague
dr. Ethan Rousseau now this is thought
to underlie some treatment resistant
conditions for example in some
populations of anorexia bulimia patients
there are mutations in the receptors for
THC and this makes a lot of conceptual
sense if the major receptors in your
brain that help control and regulate
appetite aren't functioning properly
you're not getting the signals telling
you you're hungry that may make it
difficult to treat that condition except
perhaps with a cannabinoid which would
then sort of stimulate the system to its
proper level also what's very
fascinating is you know we live in a
world surrounded by cannabinoids THC and
other famous compounds are only found on
the cannabis plant but several species
of plants make cannabinoids there's one
we may discuss a little bit today
that's a terpene that's commonly found
in black pepper but is also a
cannabinoid and stimulates receptor
if you eat a salad you're gonna eat
about 200 milligrams of
naturally-occurring non-intoxicating
cannabinoids they're just there in the
diet and they are some of these are
being studied in the clinic and then and
in animal studies for their therapeutic
uses so when we talking about producing
cannabis as a medicine I think it's
worth understanding where it's coming
from before we go into how its
administered for those of you who are
unfamiliar with plant-based medicine on
the Left we see a fairly healthy
cannabis and if we were to say target
this for extraction say we want to
purify a drug and part of the reason I
bring this up is because when this air
is a couple weeks later that we're
expecting a decision or a recommendation
by the FDA to reschedule cannabidiol
which is one of the primary cannabinoids
on the plant and to reschedule it for
the treatment of epilepsy and it is
purified from a plant plant source and
this is important because some people
are interested in why choose a plant
source over synthetics won't there be
trace amounts of T C and other things in
the purified compound yes but it's also
true for synthetic drugs which may have
other things in them too and trace
amounts resulting from a synthesis
process and the manufacturing process
but when it comes to cannabis when we're
talking about targeting it for
extraction in the making of resin
containing products whether it's for THC
and a B'nai all rich product we're not
targeting the fan leaves we're not
targeting the stem the roots these
contain little to no amounts of
cannabinoids the unfertilized flower
tops as the female plants produce oil or
resin if they do become fertilized such
as you know
field of outdoor cannabis the resin
production drops dramatically and
because it's going into sort of seed
production hemp seed does not make any
cannabinoids and it should also be noted
that hemp is just a variation or a
variety of cannabis and lots and lots of
it has to be grown because typically
it's about 5% or less THC or CBD is
produced on there so lots of it has to
be grown but largely what we're
targeting on plants are try cones that
produce the majority of these complex
majority of the cannabinoids the seeds
and the seed sprouts contains zero
cannabinoids any THC found on hemp seeds
cannabis seeds is a result of
contamination so we're talking about
cannabis products we're talking about
targeting a very specific part of
flowering top of the plant where these
special specialized trichomes are so
there's a number of ways to ingest the
fruits of cannabis and the extraction of
these trichomes um perhaps the most
common one since ancient times has been
smoking it and this again can be while
the most common route of the
administration is the least advisable
and this is mister through cigarettes
water pipes if you're wandering around
North Africa a thousand years ago you
might have used a stick or a bone
there's some very interesting artifacts
throughout the world demonstrating
people making various bowls and things
to consume cannabis it's definitely
smoking is cannabis is part of ancient
history and probably so is the chronic
coughs and respiratory issues with
smoking it also a complicated thing with
cannabis is that a lot of places in
Europe it's combined with tobacco but
this isn't
Stream Li wasteful wave in the product
at least thirty to fifty percent this
compass is loss to sidestream smoke that
is not inhale
another maybe thirty percent is
destroyed from setting it on fire
through the smoking process and it is a
very inefficient in waste process and
really no health professional advocates
for smoking of any product luckily
there's vaporization has become an
option vaporization such as the cannabis
up in the right hand corner in that
yellow pharmaceutical canister that is a
version of cannabis which meets
pharmaceutical standards and is
available in the pharmacies in Europe in
that form a whole plant form that would
be a Schedule one drug with no accepted
value however THC in solution is
scheduled to THC as a pill a Schedule
three in this country so you know if
you're playing the home game it's a
little complicated sometimes keep track
of three different scheduling categories
that th the appears it but vaporization
has been one way to reduce other carbon
dioxide and to safely deliver cannabis
but what we're talking about today with
pharmacogenomics is oral administration
since 1985 pure THC encapsulated in
sesame oil has been available and has
been used in a number of studies up
above you see dronabinol or Marinol it's
very expensive pharmaceutical medicine
and those round little balls and two and
a half five and ten milligram amounts I
like to refer to it as the caviar of
prescription medicine one because of its
appearance and two because it's very
expensive so as we're talking today
about pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics we're largely going to
be discussing cannabis in the form of
gin a banal not so much in the schedule
one form of a whole plant material
so Hardaway cannabinoid receptors work
is through g-protein coupled receptors
so if you're into pharmacology this
might be interesting but this this is
important to note because they belong to
a super family of Class A G proteins
which are among the first receptors of
this type to evolve cb1 and cb2
receptors are actually very closely
related to her Dobson which evolved in
the eye to detect light so basically
what happens is on the outside of a cell
you have an agonist or drug which binds
to a receptor and that and stimulates it
this active receptor releases a signal
into the cell amplifier so it's it's all
tightly bundled and a little G protein
complex something like teepsy stimulates
it and it sends off its downstream
cellular responses to go about their
cellular business and some of those
things involve turning on a various ion
channels activating various minuses and
protein activity but what this really
essentially boils down to is that by by
inhibiting certain ion channels by
stimulating and literally rectifying
potassium channels cannabinoid receptor
stimulation notably with cb1 results in
a decrease in transmission of neuro
chemicals such as glutamate or GABA so
if you want to price your friends say oh
I know what THC does Juice is a release
of glutamate or gaba if you have a
friend who's in pre-med they will be
impressed and this is basically how it
works if you're getting a bunch of
signals from a presynaptic neuron on the
right down to the postsynaptic reducing
the signal might be of a benefit so
there are two main receptors that have
been to come
discovered today cb1 and cb2 now in
general activation of Stevie one results
in an inhibition of neurotransmitter
release the type 2 receptor this is
primarily found throughout the immune
system and in bone cells we also have
many other proteins throughout the body
that these compounds interact with such
as GPI 55g PR e team there's also ion
channels and this is again once the drug
enters the blood stream it's going off
to the brain and other sites it is
stimulating these receptors as well as
some of these receptors on got but what
also plays a factor is how these drugs
are metabolized so first off I think
it's good when I you know I mentioned
earlier that there's a very high level
expression of the type 1 reset for the
cb1 receptor and it's really interesting
because the distribution throughout the
brain actually parallels pharmacology
you know things we can kind of see on
the nucleus of the solitary tract kids
you have target receptors in there
you're going to stimulate appetite you
have things like the hypothalamus and
amygdala things that help control
emotion fear and things like that motor
systems I sometimes think of you know
jazz musicians in cannabis when I think
of muscle memory
and things like that but also for
certain types of neuropathic pain this
could make a lot of sense in the eye
you'd find cannabinoid receptors and
this is important because there's some
one of the first indications for
cannabis as medicine was for glaucoma
and decreasing intraocular pressure we
also find that cannabinoids can interact
in the gut the immune system as well as
abundantly expressed in some cancer cell
lines as well as in many other
peripheral starts well Heart Lung
adrenal kidney liver
um you name it there's probably the
machinery of the endocannabinoids system
functioning in that
area except for the brainstem type 2
receptor is more of a immune receptor
it's abundantly expressed in bone cells
those cells that make in degrade bone
and what's fascinating about this as we
transition to our discussion of the role
genetics on pharmacology cv2
polymorphism so disease subtle changes
in the genetic code are actually
associated with osteoporosis severe
age-related osteoporosis in human
populations in mice that are genetically
pride without these receptors they have
accelerated trabecular loss this is
still a bit controversial because a lot
of the mice that are bred with out
cannabinoid receptors cb1 our cb2 or cb1
and cb2 many of them died at birth from
a failure to thrive you know that's you
don't have cannabinoid receptors it's
hard to get signals that you're gonna
eat and things like that and develop
that food reward pathway that's so
important so though there's some concern
over that model but in human populations
it's been observed in at least three
distinct it's also found on microglia
the immune cells of the brain the type
two receptor in furtive gliomas can be a
very nasty cancer and we find cb2
receptors expressed on those making them
a great target for inhibiting cancer
growth at least in laboratory models so
as far as the endocannabinoids system
goes there's been a number of reports in
both animals and humans about various
[Music]
polymorphisms and mutations
type 1 receptor which in humans is
encoded as c NR 1 is the name of the
gene for the cb1 receptor and this is
associated with
to health issues substance use disorders
neurodegenerative disorders like
Parkinson's as well as working memory
and this is again a field that's just
sort of taken off but what I wanted to
talk to you about was not so much the
mutations in these receptors which I
think will be also begin to play a role
but it's unclear how these changes
affect say th C's interaction and so we
there's there can be huge variability in
THC Tosa
for example some people use very low
doses for effective results others
require higher doses you know even for
the same condition and we can use other
things perhaps absorb other things in
your life where you know some people
will get very low doses of one thing
other people require higher doses one of
those things I'd say is is probably
coffee you know I can drink coffee
probably a couple hours before bed and
I'm fine to go to sleep
I know other people just smell it or
have a sip of it and they're up they
can't sleep for a day so again that
comes down to genetics some love so so
when you're trying to figure out the
right dose of a medicine such as THC
this may require dosed titration right
starting low trying to stay low and
sometimes taking higher amounts but that
can lead to side effects as well as
going too low can lead to ineffective
therapy there are many factors behind
this variability that's part of the
reason I started with the slides about
cannabinoid receptor mutations is I
wanted to butt out that there are many
many variables when it comes to this but
one an important factor is not just the
receptors but the liver enzymes that
analyzed our drugs and so when it comes
to pharmacogenetics matching the
pharmacy with someone's gene we've
discussed variations in the
endocannabinoids system right patient's
in the cb1 receptor mutations in the cb2
receptor as well as there's been
reported mutations and the enzymes that
synthesize and break down the naturally
occurring endo can have one specific
product it's also fascinating to me as a
pharmacologist as there are variants of
cb1 that have been produced in culture
which do respond differently to
different drugs in terms of having
different preferences for different
drugs different strengths of
interactions but what I'd like to
transition over is talking about
pharmacogenomics which is much more
broad and here we're talking about drug
transporters and drug metabolizing
enzymes now there are some really
important drug metabolizers
p-glycoprotein or ABC b1 these are very
very important for many many types of
drugs there are also drug metabolizing
enzymes on the cytochrome p450 family
and these are sometimes called sips and
these metabolize a wide wide variety of
drugs and there are many different said
for 50 isoforms except one a one six one
that THC utilizes a sip - c9 and these
again if you're putting a lot of drugs
in your gut there's gonna be some
competition here and part of our concern
especially my concern is that when
you're dealing with older populations
I've seen statistics you know people
over 50 are an average of four or five
medications those medications can have
adverse events associated with
interactions with one another and that
could potentially be two interactions at
the
SIB enzymes so there have been a few
studies that have been conducted I'm
looking and at this and taking to
account some of the pharmacogenomic
responses some of many of them are
ongoing or have not been sort of started
but what's interesting about some of the
the ones that have been published is for
example in the cb1 receptor they noticed
that there was some influence our trends
on effects of the drug THC such as
certain IBS patients irritable bowel
syndrome patients were more susceptible
to the appetite inducing effects of THC
versus other groups as well as you know
transporters of the drug can affect
their efficacy but if you're interested
in learning more about this research we
have the trial code here and some little
information you're gonna find about
these ongoing studies about the
pharmacogenomics THC and other
cannabinoids so the National two
Institutes of Health has described
pharmacogenomics which is abbreviated
PGX is the study of how genes affect the
person's response to drugs this
relatively new field combines
pharmacology and genomics to develop
effective safe medications and doses
that will be tailored to a person's
genetic makeup let's run our little
diagram up top on the left
untitled drug treatment you know we have
our genetic polymorphisms which are all
mixed up in a population you know all
the people with one mutation don't all
live in the same place we're all spread
out so it can be hard to suss out you
know one drug versus the other and so
here we're looking at these three
populations than through the yellow of
the red one population may respond very
favorably to the drug
may have no effect and when they'd be
very sensitive or susceptible to the
drug and what I mean by that is if you
look over on the right we have to see
your average THC levels and so the sips
there are three you know we each get a
copy of things one from our mother and
one from our father and if you have to
kind of bad copies you know that could
be an issue and so scientists are super
creative in the way they name things so
they found three variations and they're
named one two and three and so
participants that I had the three three
copy basically this is a this is a
different this is a less active set so
you might think of the one is sort of
the more quicker metabolizers less than
the blood right the one three you have
one copy that's not so active and one
copy that's it's very active but what we
can just see here is that when we're
comparing the average levels to each
other those that had a copy of the
relatively low level metabolizing our
active enzyme at higher levels three
three times have higher average tape
seat which you might imagine if you had
three people in the room the age took
the same amount of a drug but had
different levels of in their blood that
could lead to difficulties in getting a
consistent effect in patient populations
and the study was published in the
journal of clinical pharmacology another
interesting example of this is also I
get mentioned earlier 2c9
now this is a drug metabolizing protein
tabloids THC and many many many other
commonly prescribed pharmaceuticals with
a single amino acid change this can
basically result in much slower
clearance of th C's the first one I
showed you were
two blood levels this is now a study
that looked at clearance how quickly are
you removing it from your body and the
SIP 2c9 variant it was very poor at
clearing this from the body and this to
have a number of implications for drug
testing for how long it's around in your
body and I know I mentioned earlier too
about synthetic versus natural compounds
and with drugs such as some that are
metabolized in the kidneys some
synthetic drugs which are very effective
medicines leave behind residues and one
of the one of the things that sparked my
interest in this field was meeting a
patient who had had a pharmacogenomic
test done independently of their
physician and found out that the one
medication they were on they were an
ultra-rapid metabolizer they were taking
higher and higher and higher doses but
the metabolites leave behind a residue
that had to be cleared from the body but
it was building up a lot of this residue
for it was a drug for arthritis and
would have basically ruined his kidneys
had he continued taking this medication
he showed the results to his doctor and
the doctor actually recommended a
different drug that would not go through
the kidneys and therefore this these
residues and byproducts of metabolism
would not build up at such high levels
but that's a personal anecdote but
they're just talking about another
commonly prescribed drug but which also
could be interesting too is that if
there if you have a sip variant and
you're thinking a commonly prescribed
pharmaceutical with THC orally there can
potentially be some competition drug
drug interactions because sort of and
that can alter levels in the blood and
there is some research out there on THC
I'm in CBD being able to alter levels of
other drugs when their Co administered
orally but there are a lot of variables
here how you're consuming it mostly
we've been talking about oral
consumption today but there's also a
field of study which is fascinating
called inhalation topography this is how
people inhale things such as if we use a
classic like electronic vaporizer people
hold the button down for different
lengths of time they take different
breaths different deep you know versus
shallow breaths we have the genetic
component we talked about there's also
disease and conditions such as the type
2 receptor on the immune receptor we
mentioned that is actually triggered to
express at higher levels in certain
diseases types of cancer cells will
express high levels of cb2 receptors if
you twist your ankle you will be you
know do your cb2 receptors will elevate
to try and control that inflammation
more receptors means more targets for
the drug so again disease healthy versus
sick could potentially also be a
relevant factor to also your lifestyle
in your diet there is a field of nutria
genomics which looks at the way that
diet influences your body in terms of
your response to drugs as well and what
is really fascinating is the compounds
that THC mimic within your body the
endocannabinoids those those are
synthesized on demand
unlike other neurotransmitters they're
not stored there they're stored on
demand as needed to help regulate
homeostasis with your body and if you
don't have a lot of amazing 3 s and
omega sixes in your diet and there's
evidence and animal models that this
could make it more do
for the the endocannabinoid system to
function effect in rats that are
deprived of CB of omega-3s and omega-6s
many of their g-protein receptors just
simply don't function but all the
endocannabinoids are again synthesized
directly from cell walls which contain
different types of lipids in facts and
so your diet can potentially influence
your your potentially your interaction
with cannabis and other drugs as well so
we have a lot of factors here that can
influence someone's response I wanted to
include just a little bit of data on the
metabolism you know with when it comes
to smoking cannabis you know the
bioavailability is about 25%
so when cannabis isn't he already at
peak plasma levels in six to ten minutes
and with oral you're looking at probably
more like one to three hours for onset
for peak plasma levels but there's high
intra and Inter group variability and
it's to do those many factors probably
that I mentioned what is fascinating I
think about inhalation of cannabis is
that the metabolites generally at about
30 to 45 minutes they sort of start to
balance out with the inactive forms in
the body so you start to get this
interesting profile of metabolites about
45 minutes after inhalation and over on
the right here what I like to just point
out is perhaps just this one slide on
the top right you see whole blood you
see plasma and if you just look up and
down the plasma levels you will see
these graphs with huge error bars this
isn't a controlled study in this you
know people being administered these
cannabinoids and there's huge
variability in fact that the top graph
on the right plasma for THC the
variability is so huge they actually
left the top of the air bars off because
it wouldn't fit nice and neat in this
field so you can only see the bottom
error bars and the ranges you know a
hundred to fifteen anagrams and lead not
quite sure but uh according to this
graph the variability would be quite
quite huge and I guess the the last
thing I'd like to talk about if you're
interested in inpatient doctors seeing
me
cannabis care certification org there's
a great site powered by Harvard
University's the answer page if you're
interested more in medical in the
medical cannabis industry and training
and certification patient focused
certification is a non-profit third
party that helps to train people at
different levels as well as people
working in laboratories the
international cannabis in cannabinoid
Research Institute is a premier private
contract research organization currently
conducting clinical trials in Europe but
some of their data is free on their
website they also look at chronic safety
research which there's a fascinating
product safety study on the contaminants
in certain cannabis products that
they've acquired in Europe and tested
and they're also again engaging in some
clinical studies in wound healing the
International Research Centre on
cannabis and mental health which is
based in New York is engaging in some
much-needed work on looking at cannabis
and wellness and you know one company
just as an example the one that I have
advised navigator genomics you know we
are looking at utilizing their
technology to apply it in different
levels such as in different studies and
seeing if it can improve outcomes
predictability in different studies and
so I'd encourage you guys if you're
interested in learning more interested
in collaborating interesting what's
going on
research interested in educating
yourself these are five fairly good
organizations that have some free
resources that are putting on events and
I think that they do good stuff lastly I
like to say everything you've seen in
this presentation is from a research
study and largely they come from these
five main resources one is a recent book
chapter that dr. Ethan Risa and myself
put out called cannabis pharmacology the
usual suspects and a few promising leads
happy to send you a copy of this article
but some other really interesting
articles are listed here one that I want
to draw your attention to on the bottom
I don't get any money I'm not an author
of this book but Rodrik Pertwee's
handbook of cannabis by oxford press is
such a useful resource or you know just
a kind of a quick review by book chapter
if you want to get a quick update on
cannabis quick understanding of the
foundational knowledge it's very well
written it's actually one of the few
books that I have an e-book of that I
like so much I carry it actually on my
phone so that I can reference things
quite useful but these others studies
are very interesting because they
discuss combining drugs and how that
affects their pharmacology how that
affects their subjective effects so if
you're interested in learning more about
well what happens when we combine
different cannabinoids and combine
different cannabinoids different drugs
these are great great resources to start
and a lot of them I think are now free
and open access online with that I would
like to say you know thank you for your
time and attention in this tour of
cannabinoids and pharmacogenomics and
I'm happy to take any questions
thank you dr. Michael for that
informative presentation
we will not like the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button my answers
many questions as we have time for okay
let's get started
our first question is what does medical
cannabis cost the average person um this
is a great question and there's another
reason why I believe knowing more about
you know pharmacogenomics and more about
the endocannabinoids system can
potentially help save patients money I
think most people would be shocked to
learn that according to some of the
marijuana business organizations and
some of the statistics they've put out
that the average person who's consuming
cannabis spends about $1,200 a month
that is between eight hundred and two
thousand dollars a month on average on
medical cannabis products and again this
is not covered by insurance due to the
schedule one status so I really hope
that in the future pharmacogenomics than
we used to help patients find a medicine
that works the best for them that is
match variety of cannabis or perhaps a
particular product they look to the
route of administration help save them
money in time but yeah they the average
amount according to some research is
about twelve hundred dollars with a
range of eight hundred thousand dollars
what do pharmacogenomic tests cost
others arrange depending on all the
bells and whistles but they typically
range in about two hundred eight hundred
dollars if they're very very specific
for one mutation sometimes it can be
covered actually by insurance but
largely for getting a panel of proteins
tested is sort of nonspecific I see
everything that is
not covered by insurance but I think
it's worth the conversation with your
physician if you're interested they may
or may not have the capabilities to do
it
many IPG company keechak companies
provide additional resources and advise
for interpreting results and sharing it
health care professional and while these
tests are out there and they're between
one hundred ninety nine dollars or two
hundred dollars nine hundred dollars I
think it's it's always worth discussing
the results of your physician before you
start acting on that information when
you focus on THC but does but could this
also apply to CBD yes and I largely
focused on THC because when it has the
perhaps the most notable effects and in
CBD does not cause intoxication but it
is a concern other having a lot of
clinical studies looking at potential
drug drug interactions and and its
metabolism the human populations but it
absolutely could apply to on CBD i'm
wind which when taken orally requires
the clinical setting very very very high
doses you don't find hundreds of
milligrams for an adult's we have time
for one last question how can this help
reduce adverse events from drugs and
drug interactions I didn't spend too
much time on that but basically the sips
that we discussed you know if drugs can
be competing for those drugs can alter
the kinetics how those things are
behaving for example THC and warfarin
actually which is a blood medication and
will actually cause a worker in the need
to increase very high in the blood and
so that could potentially be an area
where you like okay well I should
engage in some precautions here and
monitor this but again I think part of
what you could do with this information
is to look at if you have if you're
consuming a cannabis based medicine to
look at the pharmaceutical drugs you're
consuming and what what sips are the
interacting with are they overlapping in
any way is one preventing the metabolism
efficiently of the other and that's
something we even see with just THC and
CBD interacting with each other in the
liver so I think that you know this
information can be helpful to
potentially look at areas where you
might be like okay there's no crossover
here I can just go with standard
precautions or maybe there's a potential
interaction or maybe there's something
that's been defined in the literature
and so by knowing a little bit more
about your genotype it's just one more
way when we're kind of arrow in the
quiver for you to use and you're in your
war chest to keep you healthy and so I
think that the point is is that by
knowing what isoforms forms of SIF you
have what variations you have can help
guide you to what the appropriate
medication or medicine might be and I
think that that is sort of the general
pathway to sussing out those drug drug
interactions and avoiding adverse events
also simple way to avoid DDI cz's
without knowing your genome your genetic
code is by looking at overlapping
symptoms like sedation for taking two
things that are are sedatives chances
are they'll increase sedation above but
you might expect were they very similar
side-effects - so again you know your
genome your genetics can help inform
part of the story but also there's just
some basic things like if - it's the
medications you're taking all have very
similar side effects that could be a
potential drug drug interaction - all
right well I would like to once again
thank dr. Marku for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab routes for
making today's educational webcast
possible and before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab groups letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye